منذ ثوره في ديسمبر 2018 مره لعمليه
السياسيه في السودان بعده مراحل واجهه
الكثير من العقبات
السياسه السودانيه في اكتوبر 2001
اعلن الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس مجلس
السياده حلى حكومه عبد الله حمدوق والغاء
العمل بمعظم بنود الوثيقه الدستوريه التي
حكمت العلاقه بين المكونين العسكري
والمدني
2001 2020 عاد بموجبه رئيس الوزراء
عبدالله لكنه سرعان بالثقال
على خط الازمه في التاسعه والعشرين من
ديسمبر 2001 2020 عبر ما سماها خريطه
الطريق لاسترداد الشرعيه
في السودان اطلاقا مشاورات اوليه هي عمليه
سياسيه الشامله لحالي ازمه البلاد الهيئه
الحكوميه للتنميه بشرق افريقيا ايجاد
تقدمت في الحادي عشر من يناير 2022
او 2021 بمبادره اخرى قبل ان تلتئمه هي
والامم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي متى
يعرف بالاليه الثلاثيه
تضمنت 12
ونحو 76 ماده
وقع المكونان العسكري والمدني على ما عرف
بالاتفاق الايطالي